hey I'm Alexis and I'm watching the very
first episode of chef hot water and I'm
a little nervous I haven't watched it in
a really long time okay let's see it it
looks like it's covered in warts it's
like is it burning this is gonna be
weird got really weird I'm Alexis and
I'm the senior food specialist here at
Taste State today my co-workers
challenged me to make a three-course
meal using only one appliance do I get
to choose what appliance oh I look so
happy in like innocent and just like
ready for anything but I'm like oh if
only you knew what was gonna come I had
no idea that I was gonna make a coffee
maker like zero idea I don't drink
coffee and I think I've made coffee
three times in my life I I don't I don't
my god how about this works any good
chef should be able to cook with with
anything so I'm up for the challenge
this is true like I don't drink coffee I
don't make coffee I was a fish out of
water
you know I've cooked using all sorts of
appliances but the coffee maker just
felt so out of left field
which I guess is the point
[Music]
short-hair made three and a half ounces
of heavy cream it seems like very little
I guess we just heat it up and see how
hot it gets this happened many times
over the series where like something was
burning or something was like miss when
the cream started to smell like it was
burning I was like how am i messing up
already there's no way I'm gonna be able
to do this and it smells like it's
burning fine the cream doesn't need to
be scalding hot and you want it like
more than warm to the touch if you stuck
your finger in it you'd be like ha how
long does it take to make coffee in the
morning like 10 minutes more will it
work I feel like watching this I'm
watching someone else I'm like oh what
is she doing oh this is so and get the
water going for my shrimp I fear that
it's gonna take a while so that's why
you add the water to first I think this
was a learning experience of like how to
make coffee you know it's like with this
really basic thing that everyone else
knows how to do and I somehow miss so
having it on this is a real learning
experience here it feels hot so I think
I can actually go ahead and add the
shrimp this is why that stupid haircut
doesn't work for cooking it's too short
it doesn't say an opponent oh that's why
I grew my hair so we just want to make
sure that the shrimp is cooked through
and pink.you exact turning pink you can
see it turning pink this is amazing
coffee cooking my confidence level right
now I mean I don't want to get cocky but
I feel pretty optimistic they're
actually like perfect like they were
actually able to toast the coconut on
the griddle it was amazing because doing
it in the coffee pot it was like
perfectly poached it felt like magic it
was so exciting
honestly this might be the best shrimp
I've ever made I feel skeptical
so I guess I'll just let that get a
little toasty if it does I feel like I
would serve this at a dinner party or
just make it for myself that's another
reason I feel so excited about this is
I'm actually making food I feel
passionate about Oh oh my god it's
actually working it's working it's
working
we're not somebody gives you some mobile
ground I feel excited oh the coconut got
a little brown and you taste some of the
toasted flavor Wow I don't know if I'm
allowed to say like give myself a pat on
the back but this is really good next
I'm going to poach the salmon so I'm
just gonna heat it up like I did before
and it needs to be enough oil to
submerge the salmon and I'm just gonna
trim the salmon down so that it'll
actually fit in the cuff but I'm gonna
infuse the oil with watching this back
I'm like I sound really confident why
this whole roller coaster of emotions
some peppercorns lemon rinds or dill and
that all heat up together and infuse I
feel like I could have been fused it
more so I had this idea to make these
asparagus ribbons and I was initially
thinking about blanching them but I
think actually I could steam them in the
steamer basket because this darkness is
so thin stamina is gonna work better
than Blanche Annette stay tuned this is
like the weirdest thing but that was the
rudest thing I've ever done it could be
done anywhere from like 7 to 15 minutes
so while the salmon is poaching I'm just
that's an okay so I said 7 to 15 minutes
but like it's a coffee maker
the timing leg alt I mean that you would
use and any other like cooking method is
just out the window I don't know if
anyone actually thought this was gonna
work oh um this looks really gross the
fat is clearly moving it's not that it's
not that after so many commentary it's
not that it's like the blah blah protein
blah blah I almost they're kind of
mystic what it is but it's not that
you mean the salmon but it looks like oh
my god
it looks like it's covered in words
there's like little balls okay okay but
look how beautiful that is
look at that I'm gonna do hideous
beautiful and then wipe off my fat no
one will ever know ten million B well
the salmon finishes poaching I'm gonna
roll the truffles in the cocoa powder
I'm gonna go chill T's again and then my
salmon should be ready
oh the day looks like a sea creature
likes a little weird
let me just flake this okay I mean it
looks beautiful okay it looks did I say
it looks beautiful
that's great you saw fly really nice you
can do olive oil poached salmon in a
coffee maker
I knew the flavor okay it does look
disgusting it doesn't look beautiful I
don't know what I'm saying but the
flavor was so good it was so good and it
was cooked perfectly but this I'm gonna
like simmer some beans in chicken stock
and Tyler for Costa try to add some more
flavor I should have written that
Sparrow to top and then add some more
chicken stock by the time the chicken
stock goes through it might be done I
don't I don't know
oh my god it's like all right it's
already it's done it's not mushy
they're beautiful don't want to speak
too soon but it's going this is going
surprisingly well
[Music]
okay I don't know why I ate the
asparagus like that like why did I do
that that's not how you eat food
you're just seemed like the inner the
inner parts you know the coconut got
toasted have really nice color hopefully
they can get some char he's my favorite
oh okay there's some sound there's a
little bit of a little bit of darken a
little bit of darkened what does that
mean a little bit of darken isn't okay
I'm almost done so I'm gonna text some
friends see if they want to come up and
try it and see if they know that this
was all done with a coffee maker of
course one is a mouse it's not amazing I
left you with the coffee maker olive oil
poached salmon steamed asparagus ribbons
and blistered tomatoes when you left me
this morning what did you think was
gonna happen
pour hot water in there I was so like
taste tests always make me so nervous I
made all three courses using only a
coffee maker ah I could have eaten that
meal in a restaurant
[Music]
clearly no share this with the team
coffeemaker clean up and makeup Queen
going into today I was nervous this is
crazy this takes so long but if I was
ever in a pinch if there's the
apocalypse I can make dinner at a coffee
maker I'll be fine
oh my god that was a whole world over
promotions I felt nervous I felt excited
I felt scared for the outcome even
though I knew the outcome and it was me
and I already did it but I felt scared
watching it again because it was like
all these things but it's really cool
it's actually really fun to see you know
it's time to watch it back and like
remember why people are connected to it
it's so weird I think this was actually
like maybe one of my favorite videos
that I've ever done I would absolutely
put up again in coffee maker like
happily since this episode I have still
not made coffee in a coffee pot
[Music]